arguing with a crazy person accomplishes
nothing hey guys I'm kaya and I am Scott
I'm tayo I'm Alex and today we're doing
never have I ever the McDonald's Edition
started working McDonald's the summer in
1996 best summer of my life I started
work at McDonald's when I was about 18
until I was about 20 years old I went to
McDonald's from 2005 to 2006 my junior
year going my senior year at high school
I worked there from February 2018 to
July of 2018 back in Orlando Florida so
while working there it's not a lot of
things that I have not done there we're
gonna find out
never have I ever suggested my friends
or family not to be an item at
McDonald's I have the breakfast
sandwiches I thought it was really gross
that they heated the excitement in my
voice I have it was a salad if you're
not ordering french fries what's the
point of going to McDonough
my mom was going to try the McRib and I
suggested she didn't eat it I got a bite
of something not amazing when I tried to
eat it sound like well maybe like maybe
don't know food even tasted good never
have I ever thought about quitting
midship I have yes I have thought about
quitting mid-shift multiple times those
days and I'd be like it's not even a
customer that pissed me off it was the
manager if you're staring too long so
giving your ass it was the most annoying
thing in the world never have I ever
spit four words in someone's food I've
not that's disgusting that's tripping
Spain in somebody's food that's that's
next level I'm who's too lazy to
actually do that I have not but I know
someone at my job did worse and yeah
that's all I'm gonna say about that
never have I ever made a ridiculous
burger or anything when you were bored
I actually have not and I wish I did my
friends would like tell the cooks feel
like apple slices in their burger or
what not and of course it really never
turned out good but it was so fun to see
what they created I have not got the
perfect food at McDonald's why would you
want to change it not a burger but fries
we put like the sauce from one of the
burgers we mix it with fries it would be
the greatest thing ever but they should
put on the menu what was it the chicken
sandwich I used to just be like a double
chicken sandwich so instead of have I
like the small lady like double a Big
Mac Big Mac person going to recently
sugar lump and end dates oh my god
triple big man I call it triple Mac you
trying to kill people
never have I ever been threatened by a
customer
late nights when you work drive-through
you never know what to expect I've
definitely gotten cursed out once it
wasn't even like the client the customer
was upset at me I just remembers getting
cursed I'm like okay have a good day sir
that was so scared to get cussed out by
people I was like my worst fear
I have not when the crazy customers
start talking crazy you go okay to
whatever they say because arguing with a
crazy person accomplishes nothing
yeah I've been threatened someone
threatened to shoot me in the parking
lot one time I had pulled up I was
walking like walking to the entrance
start my shift and someone just came up
and was like what are you doing like I'm
gonna shoot you if I ever see you again
I'm gonna shoot you and like sure yeah I
never saw them again never knew who that
was but yeah there was a time customer
threatened to shoot me never have I ever
bartered McDonald's food for something
else oh yeah yeah you're done right I
did we had all different kind of
restaurants in the plaza you went to the
bagel place and you're like I'll give
you a Big Mac you give me a pizza bagel
that's a wholesome trade yes I have this
is gonna sound weird but it was between
other McDonald's disses of ours a lot of
times we would run out of things like
say apple slices are like even burger
patties and we called them up and say
hey
you need anything we have because we
need something that you probably have
and every day we'd be like jogging back
and forth trying to like trade and
barter for supplies I don't know if I
would love to say this on camera but I
have bartered McDonald's food for blunts
never have I ever cussed at a customer I
have not have not I think it's kind of
custom now but I was like you need to
wait basically damn never have I ever
even / ordered at a competitor's store
with my uniform ah okay I have not
bought
I still got my uniform okay from 1996 I
have I go to the mall after my shift
sometimes and Monday I went to Panda
Express to order something and they're
like oh you work at McDonald's I said X
I was in my uniform I said yeah I do
like I haven't seen you around but the
employees who work at the McDonald's
like are the food restaurants in the
mall they get a discount I was like I
didn't work at the one in the mall but I
just took the discount any time it was
offered I'm not here Burger King was
right across the street was at the
Hershey Pie Hershey Park that was never
have I ever seen a co-worker do
something they would get fired for I
have not and the reason I have not is
because this is on record I ain't no rat
I don't work there anymore so yes I have
I have seen managers steal money from
the drawers from the registers from the
safe on cam reminds you I have I saw
someone sneak into the manager's little
room and eat a whole big night mommy's
just food all over Lee what do you
explain I'm used to big basketball with
never have I ever dropped food on the
ground and still served it
I have not people come on no that's low
that's like spraying somebody's food
unprotected food and I tossed it out if
it went to the floor I hope you guys
enjoyed these never have I ever
questions and I hope you guys get some
more insights on what we do do it
McDonald's or don't do
McDonald's employees you're gonna have
some good some bad some ugly but
ultimately we're all in the business of
serving the greatest food in the history
of the world McDonald's french fries I
didn't realize how many things I have
done and might not be so proud but yeah
overall it's fun to like look back I
don't like the memories I had there and
through this game it kind of helped me
remember some stuff
[Music]